okay stimmt ist dass wenn etwas auf den
boden fällt dass man es manchmal noch
auf den dollar drücken
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei anderen video hören
natürlich geht es gut uns auch und zwar
habe ich heute stelle ich mal kurz war
ich bin lisa genau das ist lisa die hat
sich heute freundlicher weise dazu
bereit erklärt mit mir dieses kleine
interview zu führen weil ich ja vor
einer woche dann video hochgeladen habe
da habe ich so eine ehemalige mcdonald's
mitarbeiterin interviewt weißt du die
mir heute geschrieben hat ja ich kann
dir mal ein paar fragen beantworten und
das habe ich halt dankend angenommen und
wir haben also ein kleines interview
geführt die zuschauer konnten ganz viele
fragen stellen und die habe ich ihr halt
gestellt und viele haben gesagt ey macht
das doch wieder auch mal mit burger king
und da du ja länger weil hin gearbeitet
hast fast das ganz gut und es kam mir da
sehr viele fragen auf die wir jetzt
gleich mal durchgehen werden und du
kannst ja einfach dann wenn du was dazu
sagen willst was dazu sagen und wenn du
zu irgendwas nichts sagen darf weil es
irgendwie betriebsgeheimnis ist oder
sonst was das auch kein problem kein
kannst du es einfach sagen okay also ja
soweit alles geklärt ich wünsche euch
viel spaß und wenn ihr auch einen
interessanten beruf habe oder so
vielleicht irgendwas mit essen schreibt
mir gern bei instagram da ist ja alex
wie und da können wir dann mal drüber
wenn ihr bock habt ok alles klar
es ist immer so typisch dass manche
fragen gibt es dann mega auf all das zu
fragen sind die halt jeden interessieren
ich würde sagen wir können eigentlich
mit dieser standard frage anfangen weil
das halt weiß ich nicht das ist halt
immer das meist bestellte und dann ist
sie schon mal weg und zwar bei der sich
ja was ganz besonderes du hast ja erst
bei burger king gearbeiteten arbeitet
jetzt bei mcdonald's richtig wie lange
hast du denn bei burger king gearbeitet
ein jahr von 2 17 bis 28 10
und dann ist das zu einem mcdonald's
geworden und da arbeitest du jetzt genau
und vielleicht um das mal so vorwerk zu
klären was hat dir besser gefallen
deutlich also die arbeit da war weniger
anstrengend finde ich persönlich
war also dadurch dass der mac
deutschlands ausgebaut wurde ist halt
der fläche wo wir hin und herlaufen
müssen da habe ich dass der berggänger
kleiner war hatten wir das im kurs
standen und vielleicht auch also das
haben viele gefragt warum ist in vielen
bands fast nie was los ich weiß es nicht
er sich nicht also ich persönlich mag
die bürger darauf lieber also ist ja
jedem selbst überlassen wer es lieber
mag aber keine ahnung als ich finde die
angebote selbst werken besser ich
persönlich mag das fleisch darüber weil
es ein bisschen saftiger ist aber also
ja gut kann man ja auch wahrscheinlich
so es kommt natürlich auch auf den laden
an wurde jetzt liegt aber ich habe das
auch manchmal dass ich an den bürgern
vorbei fahren und da halt einfach kein
mensch drin sitzt und so die meisten
mcdonald sind ja schon immer relativ gut
besucht sagen wir mal so ok und dann
jetzt zu der frage die ich eben meinte
was verdient man denn wenn du das sagen
da es beim working pro stunde oder was
hast du verdient
8 euro 50 also du hast 39 oder 9 euro
ach so also 450 euro basis weil ich
glaube bei mcdonald's ich weiss ist
jetzt mal ganz genau aber da war das
auch auf jeden fall mindestlohn oder 9
euro meinte sie glauben ja alles klar
gut dann haben wir das wichtigste war
geklärt mal schauen was die leute noch
so gefragt haben das ist mir schon oft
passiert und zwar ist das oft passiert
es leute da rein kamen und sich halt mit
den bürgern so vertan haben dass man
gesagt hat einen bigmac ja da durch das
bei uns vor der burger king drin war
manche vorangekommen die haben mit noch
gar nicht gecheckt dass da jetzt ein mac
ist und war die sich anschicken haben
wir nicht wegschicken
warum wieso bei burger king wir haben
umgebaut
aber es kommt schon ein paar mal vor
die aber auch und da ja stimmt ja aber
wurde dann halt früher da noch
gearbeitet das ist das schon oft
passiert dass leute halt einfach so weil
es waren vielleicht weil man das so drin
hat dass man einfach die ruhe weg
anstatt ein peking oder einmal die
chicken mcnuggets da ging es mit dem big
mac eher weniger vorkommen aber mit dem
weg in baar neckar softer und chicken
mcnuggets das wurde beim working so oft
gesagt also habe ich mich dann im
innerlichen habe ich mir gedacht okay
stimmt es dass wenn etwas auf den boden
fällt dass man es manchmal noch auf dem
ball getroffen also bei uns definitiv
nicht also was auf den boden fällt
gehört und weil ich glaube da ist jetzt
auch da ist jetzt war ja so ein video
auch im internet was die runde gemacht
hat wo das war in den mcdonald's da hat
der bürger mitarbeiterinnen oder jemand
der in der küche war irgendwie das
fleisch auf den boden getrieben und dann
drauf getan also das habe ich mal wurden
wir irgendwie mal so zugeschickt
deswegen aber das war ist wahrscheinlich
dann immer ein extremfall also ich habe
jetzt von dijon wird und auch schon von
der vorherigen die bei mcdonald's
gearbeitet hat das ist alles wirklich
hygienisch absolut und du hast ja auch
mal in der küche gearbeitet na ja also
es wird immer die arbeitsfläche sauber
gehalten musst also es sind halt
standards nicht eingehalten werden
müssen
der grill muss immer sauber gemacht
werden also es läuft wirklich hygienisch
ab und auf gar keinen fall wird da war
es auch okay alles klar haben wir das
auch geklärt ach so also das haben auch
viele gefragt also weil das jetzt halt
nur logisch folge ist weil ich heute den
ersten paar schon gemacht habe aber
jetzt du besitzt ja praktisch eine
quelle wo hast du dann mehr vor den
beiden einfach mindestlohn ja genau also
dadurch dass dann ja innerhalb des
nächsten jahres den inseln erhöht wurde
aber man verdient halt nur mindestlohn
und du darfst auch kein trinkgeld an den
richtig nett trinkgeld auf drei berking
auch nicht auch nicht ja das war bei
mcdonald's ähnlich nur dann
unterscheiden die sich ja gar nicht mal
so stark wie so ist bei burger king
sesam auf dem burger brötchen und bei
mcdonald's nicht das ist eine gute frage
ja wenn du es nicht weiß dann weiß es
nicht also nicht meine du bist ja auch
du bist ja auch nicht der bürger ideen
finden also weißt du das hat war schon
hängt wahrscheinlich mit der geschichte
zusammen einfach bei mcdonald's war es
am anfang ohne sesam und bei berg mit
sesam und deswegen habe ich es auch bei
ball oder ja alles klar
gut möglich dass wenn du halt dort
arbeit ist schon immer vom essen coating
gebrochener nase überhaupt nicht also
man kommt halt dahin man hat das
fritteuse fetsch in der nase sagen ich
mal so du hast eher weniger hunger habe
ich das gefühl darauf das zu essen also
so in den pausen ist klar man sich mal
als mann kann mit seinen individuellen
burger behaupte mal zusammen stellen
aber klar müssen wir dafür zahlen es
gibt nichts umsonst aber an sich also
man an der kasse arbeitet riecht man das
sowieso nicht so krass er weiter hinten
in der küche dann aber ich würde jetzt
nicht sagen das ist so geil rief das du
denkst ich muss jetzt unbedingt noch
einen dicken burger essen und die ganzen
kids auf dem kühlschrank holen ja okay
und also da du ja jetzt sogar ist das
bei du arbeitest aktuelle zucker bei
mcdonald's und ist das ja auch so dass
du halt jede stunde die ihr sohn
essensgeld an arbeitest
das heißt wenn nur neun stunden
gearbeitet hast und jede stunde mal
angenommen ist 50 cent bekommst dass du
da halb für 450 essen ach so
das haben wir bei uns anders also wir
bekommen 50 prozent mitarbeiter rabatt
auf normale bestellung ab 4 euro 50
alles was drunter ist da kriegen wir
auch keinen rabatt drauf welt sondern
einfach zu wenig ist und auf die coupons
auch nicht und bei burger king wie war
das doch genauso dann damals hatten wir
nach zehn prozent aber ich glaub das
wird am ende irgendwie abgeändert aber
ich glaube das ist auch von betrieb zu
betrieb unterschiedlich ist wie in der
raststätte sind das ach so also dass du
dann einfach zehn prozent auf die
bestellung bekommst genau weil das ja
eigentlich ist ja nicht viel
also weil das da gehen halt mega viele
von aus so die denke halt wenn ihr
gearbeitet dass wir die ganze zeit essen
dürfen sonst und trinken dürfen sonst
aber das ist nicht so na gut dann haben
wir mit dem gerücht auch mal eingeräumt
falls man das so nennt aber trinken das
umsonst bekommen wasserflaschen zur
verfügung aber das alles klar
gibt es also das habe ich jetzt bei dir
zwei mal oder bei den fragen zu beugen 2
mal gelesen gibt es manchmal leute die
hinter die kasse gehen und sich ein
bürger nehmen clown ist schon mal
passiert also mir ist jetzt noch nicht
vorgekommen ich habe noch nie davon
gehört dass es passiert aber wir machen
die bestellung meistens auch erst als
wir machen die nicht auf stock sondern
erst wenn wirklich bestellt wird damit
es halt möglichst frisch ist es ist in
dem größeren kinder natürlich anders
aber okay und wenn du jetzt mal so an
den zeitplan zurück denkt was war so die
krasseste situation mit einem kunden
oder irgendwie das unangenehmste hast du
da irgendwie so eine situation kommt
also ich bin meistens immer übertrieben
netz wenn ich an der kasse stehen räder
mit einer tonlagen di so 10 stufen höher
ist als meine eigentliche stimme
deswegen hab ich eigentlich meistens
kein problem mit den gästen bekommen
aber einmal war eine rauda und die
wollte chili cheese nuggets haben und
wir haben die grad frisch aus der
fritteuse geholt das hat man eigentlich
auch also hätte man sehen können wir
darauf geachtet hätte und ich habe die
dann war wie geholt und sie meinte nicht
mehr frische haben ja die sind gerade
frisch aus der fritteuse nein ich
arbeite bei burger king ich weiß das
wie das da abläuft ich will frische
haben einfach mehr geht eigentlich nicht
habt ihr dann trotzdem wieder nach
hinten gebracht weil man muss ja net
sekunden sein und habe dann noch mal
neue eingegangen waren hat sie wieder
gesagt dass die schiffe und dann hast du
hier die hinterher geworfen werden
wer also wer hat dann wirklich drauf
geachtet dass sie wirklich die bekommen
habt ihr aus der fritteuse kam aber es
war glaube ich bei mir mit auch schon
die extremste situation und bei einem
anderen mitarbeiter das was viele halt
glaub ich als mitarbeiter stürzt wenn
werden telefon angekommen sind
telefonieren bestellen und wird die
bestellung aufnehmen hinten steht schon
eine riesenschlange und fragt ja ketchup
mayo und der ist am telefon rede ja was
willst du von mir und ja da war ein
anderer der wahl relativ neu da wurden
noch eingearbeitet und der kunde war wie
gesagt und telefon und hat überhaupt
nicht auf dem mitarbeiter reagiert und
auf die bestellung und plötzlich fing
dann an herumzuschreien ja sehen sie
nicht dass ich am telefonieren bin passt
was denken sie eigentlich wer sie sind
und dann haben die sich heute ein
bisschen angelegt und da musste dann
auch der schichtführer kommen und den
beruhigen und die situation ein bisschen
schlecht ja ok alles klar
ja das ist auch nur super interessante
frage die ich mich selber auch schon mal
gestellt hat war das ist richtiges
deutsch die ich mir mir irgendwie habe
ich es heute nicht so ganz auf jeden
fall wäscht man sich oft die hände
hinter der theke oder gibt es ja
irgendwie eine regelung dass man dass
jede stunde macht oder so also wenn man
klar vom toilettengang beziehungsweise
wenn man gerade die schlecht anfängt und
dass man sich die hände waschen mit
seife und dass infektionen und es gibt
auch ne also falls dann hin von der
desinfizieren austrocknen gibt so eine
körperlose hause eine handcreme die auch
schnell eins sieht damit es kein problem
wird und sobald man irgendwie seinen
eigenen körper sag ich mal irgendwie
anfasst muss man sich aus hygienischen
gründen die hände waschen und beim salat
gibt es halt dran schuhe noch alles klar
ja gut und vielleicht noch den schlüssel
sache du hast ja auch mal in der küche
gearbeitet als köchin und verdient man
da gleich viel
ja es ist alles gleich also kann auch
für beides an
gelernt also falls irgendetwas passieren
sollte und ein anderer mitarbeiter
ausfällt dass man dann auch einspringen
kann ich andere personal und das war bei
mcdonald's und burger gleich beiden also
das war als ich weiß jetzt einen
größeren vier jahren aus weil die halt
viel mehr mitarbeiter haben als wir
ob es bei denen dann getrennt ist dass
die getrennt angelernt werden ich weiß
es nicht aber es ist halt mit beiden ok
alles klar
leute dann gehen wir erst mal davon aus
dass wir vielleicht noch ein paar
weitere fragen stellen das ist dann
allerdings ein zweiter park weil dieses
video jetzt schon ziemlich lang geht ich
bedanke mich bei dir ja das war's warte
julis frage war dir selbst euch hellwig
punkte geben bei burger
ach so ja okay also payback das ist so
ein pay back system weiß sieger zahlst
du dann geld und chris payback punkte ja
aber dürfen wir nicht also ich habe mal
gehört dass man theoretisch beiträge
einfach einstecken kann aber nein das
ist definitiv nicht alle alles klar dann
meinetwegen kannst du deine interessen
erwähnt lisa hübner unterstrich
unterstrich oder ein bindestrich also
unten unterstrich und nicht nur unten
strich ja ich bin alles klar dann danke
dir
haut rein morgen gibt's um 19 uhr ein
weiteres video shows und mein instagram
ist auch hier kurz alex unterstrich